Why Does Toothpaste Make Things Like Orange
Juice Taste So Awful?
You may think the reason toothpaste makes
things like orange juice taste so awful is
simply due to the common mint flavor of toothpaste
clashing with other flavors, but this isn’t
actually what’s going on here.
The real culprit is thought to be two compounds
almost universally added to toothpastes -sodium
lauryl sulfate and sodium lauryl ether sulfate,
which are anionic surfactants, meaning they
lower the surface tension of water.
Why is that desirable in toothpaste?
Because it works as something of a detergent,
and makes the toothpaste foam to help it spread
around inside your mouth easier.
Besides any cleaning effect, this has the
by-product of making you feel like the toothpaste
is doing something, which toothpaste manufacturers
have found to be a great way to get people
to buy more of their toothpaste.
Mint is added to toothpaste for this same
reason, as it leaves your mouth feeling cool,
clean, and fresh, particularly if it’s well
distributed throughout your mouth.
As Tracy Sinclair, one-time brand manager
at Oral-B stated in the book The Power of
Habit, by Charles Duhigg,
Consumers need some kind of signal that a
product is working.
We can make toothpaste taste like anything
— blueberries, green tea — and as long
as it has a cool tingle, people feel like
their mouth is clean.
The tingling doesn’t make the toothpaste
work any better.
It just convinces people it’s doing the
job.
(Interestingly enough, besides any real cleaning
effect, sodium lauryl sulfate is added to
shampoo for similar marketing reasons, as
people perceive that foaming shampoo works
better than non-foaming, whether a particular
brand’s foaming shampoo actually cleans
better than some other non-foaming shampoo
or not.)
Back to your taste-buds -the sodium lauryl
sulfate interacts with your sweet taste receptors,
making them less sensitive, and thus dulling
the sweet flavor.
In addition to that, it also destroys phospholipids
in your mouth, which are compounds that have
the same type of effect sodium lauryl sulfate
has on sweet taste buds, except the phospholipids
dampen your bitter taste buds.
The net effect is that your sweet taste buds
are dampened while your bitter taste buds
become more sensitive.
So when you drink something like orange juice,
which normally has an overpowering sweet taste
that masks an underlying bitter taste, it
is going to taste drastically different -in
this case extremely bitter.
So if for some reason your morning routine
includes brushing your teeth before eating,
you can simply find toothpaste that is free
of sodium lauryl sulfate, and sodium lauryl
ether sulfate and the food you eat directly
after shouldn’t taste awful, unless you’re
bad at cooking, of course.
Sodium lauryl sulfate has been shown to act
as a shark repellent.
There is also evidence that it is effective
as a microbicide when spread on your skin,
particularly effective in helping to prevent
infection from viruses like Herpes simplex
and HIV, which are non-enveloped viruses.